scans now
look we may not have actual dungeons or
dragons to offer you but this week's
picks will still be pretty fire along
with the Double D we have another game
inspired movie to fit into your viewing
schedule plus a critical darling drama
and a new series on Netflix and the
streaming release of something big blue
and extremely lucrative Rotten Tomatoes
is putting all of your blocks in just
the right spots that's weird on this
week's what to watch on your knees
okay chop it off chop it off let's do it
no
entering theaters this week is Dungeons
and Dragons honor among Thieves based on
the classic RPG tabletop game alright to
answer everyone's question when you're
certified fresh at 89 with a 94 audience
score yes the movie is that awesome
regardless if you played the game or not
top critic Lex brascuso basically agrees
with us on this one saying his review of
DnD h-a-t extremely accessible and
enticing for non-fans right from the
jump while also satisfying hardcore
devotees of the game but if you need
more convincing this cast is Pitch
Perfect Chris Pine who needs spells when
you have that much charm seriously
Michelle Rodriguez and Sophia lillis are
the calvary of the group leading some
impressive action sequences and you
won't be rolling your eyes at Hugh Grant
who continues to grow outside being the
king of rom-coms here and plays a
complete Lord of douchebaggery he's come
a long way since Notting Hill you're
lying everybody
recovery is coming we don't have time I
have a plan
[Music]
if you were less a tabletop game kid and
more of a Game Boy kind of kid perhaps
Tetris will drop perfectly into a vacant
weekend watch spot for you this weekend
in his first project since wowing Us in
Blackbird last year Taryn Edgerton stars
in this true and wild story about the
high stakes legal battle to secure the
property rights to Tetris in the late
1980s who would have thought you'd hear
high stakes and Tetris in the same
sentence reception to the film has been
largely positive being certified fresh
on the Tomato Meter and while you could
read into the critics consensus I'll
just paraphrase instead by saying that
it doesn't quite give you the feeling of
clearing four rows at once but it comes
dang close I got a war for you you know
that against anybody
against this whole city but they're not
breaking us up this time
opening in theaters this week is a drama
called a thousand and one and while
we're talking numbers here's three great
reasons to check this one out for
starters it premiered at the Sundance
Film Festival in January and took home
the grand jury prize that ain't no
participation trophy it marks the
feature film debut for director AV
Rockwell who is already making a name
for herself on the big stage much like
the film star singer Tayana Taylor and
1001 is certified fresh currently
hovering around the high 90s so far with
top critic Robert Daniels from the
playlist saying that it's a
breathtakingly beautiful portrait of
black Womanhood and is thoughtfully
political
the more you know the more dangerous
this becomes
no idea what you're getting into and
because you couldn't open up social
media without hearing about this one our
trending pick if you will is the Netflix
series The Night agent this action
thriller about a low-level FBI agent who
works in the basement of the White House
did come out last week but seemingly
over the weekend Rose to become one of
the most watched pieces of entertainment
but don't take our word for it here are
some stats Netflix tweeted that it
debuted at number one on their English
TV list with nearly 170 million hours
viewed additionally it is the most
viewed show page on rottentomatoes.com
right now and sure on the Tomato Meter
we're not in certified fresh territory
but that didn't stop Netflix from
officially announcing the night agent
has been renewed for season two if you
want to live here
you have to ride
let's do it
and if you are finally ready to see
avatar The Wave water for the first or
second or third time get ready to dive
into the Waters of Pandora on Voodoo if
saying that there's 2.3 billion reasons
to see this one sounds a bit too obvious
AKA it's Global box office haul I'm
doing it anyway because that's a lot of
money as in the third highest grossing
film of all time money plus since its
release the certified fresh film also
enjoyed a fun Oscars night where it was
nominated for Best Picture among other
Awards and obviously one for best visual
effects and once you finally see the way
of water or see it again it's gonna be
time to look ahead to the sequels with
Avatar 3 in 2024 Avatar 4 in 2026 and
Avatar 5 in 2028
well there it is the absolute most
perfect options for what to watch this
week let us know which ones you plan to
catch but also help others out in the
comments if we happen to miss anything
remember to check out rottentomatoes.com
for the latest updates on scores and
reviews for everything mentioned as well
as the movie and TV World At Large and
of course continue to check out the new
rt25 page where we'll be celebrating 25
years of rotten tomatoes with articles
dedicated to our history best of lists
and hey look at that our brand new card
game putting your cinephile mind to the
test on 25 years of Tomato Meter scores
come on go check it out you know you
want to play it that's all for today
fresh family and until next week
continue to stay fresh
[Music]